I read somewhere that you like Ernest
Hemingway love him there's a quote
there's nothing to writing all you do is
sit down at a typewriter and bleed do
you agree with that I agree I agree well
I agree with that with journaling
because I can't write um
I can't write stand up like I can't
write a bit but if I Journal I'll find
something that I go just right
kind of writing where your the Pen's
moving faster than your brain and
they're kind of like doing it together
the thing I liked about Ernest Hemingway
this is so stupid
I'm a little dyslexic so I'm not a good
reader and so he wrote very simply
and it wasn't until after I read a bunch
of Ernest Hemingway I was working in
parts of the noble and this person said
don't you love his titles and I was like
yeah someone else arises and they're
like yeah but
no The Sun Also Rises and I was like
yeah it's almost Rises and they're like
no this no the Sun Also arises and I
went oh
oh yeah that is [__] badass yeah and
then I'm like always late to the party
with anything and then that night we
were all doing coke and uh it was like
five in the morning and we ended up on
the roof of my apartment in Greenwich
Village
um the the like I'm a sunset guy I go up
in Florida but Sunrise is in New York
are electric blue like electric blue
and I was like The Sun Also Rises
yeah he was so good
with just a handful of words yeah the
Simplicity the choice of words like uh
basically his process is carving down
right drunk edit Sober by drunk at it
sober yeah but he was good at like at
like
a small amount of words to to get a
point across I'm the exact [__]
opposite well he's also said uh the
first draft of anything's always [__]
is that uh is that true for you I think
so
the best one I have he goes downhill
from there so for you editing is
destroying the original the first time
the first time I tell it it's perfect
it's perfect it just it works and then I
go great and then I take it and I try to
fix it and make it better and jazzier I
just joke and Razzle Dazzle about my
daughters and I driving past the deaf
child's line
and uh I just told it on stage it just
happened and Louie was in the audience
because I love that joke I said really
he was yeah and I just told it and I
went done Louis CK says he likes a joke
it's [__] it's in the special
and I tried to [__] Razzle Dazzle
that joke into like a 15 minute bit it
got to the point where it was so
obnoxious it was so bad that I I told
him I did a podcast with him I said what
did you like about that joke because I
can't get it to work anymore because it
was just simple it was simple that your
daughter didn't know how they'd figure
out where deaf kids lived oh that's it
he's like yeah I was like nothing about
gun control and he was like huh I was
like oh [__] man I really [__] that
joke up and then I had to I had to go
back to the beginning of it but that
first time
that's when that's when the joke comes
out purest for me and then it's always
chasing back to get that get that first
telling some jokes are different like
the machine obviously was a much longer
story and like in like escape room for
this one the longer stories take a
little work but the the simple ones
like like the deaf child in pajamas and
those first times are perfect